the most common words that languages
borrow from each other are nouns words
for things probably since it's fairly
straightforward to point at an object
say the word for it and have the other
person understand that's what you're
talking about things like fire or
chicken are easier Concepts to
communicate and say awesome or the and
probably more immediately useful for
trading the basics of living also there
are so many things that humans give
different names to so if you go through
a list of Lone words into a particular
language lots of them will be creatures
and objects that speakers of that
language would never have encountered at
home that's the first of the two main
ways that words get moved between
languages as loan words through most of
history people would go to a new place
ask what the name of a local thing is
get a response and then start calling
the thing that name sometimes though the
word they were given wasn't a name so
much as a description of what the thing
was or a category we don't know the
exact derivation but some North American
languages use a word like pakan for any
hard nut but it became the English word
for the pecan nut or pecan nut the
Arabic words are haraha for deserts
became the English word specifically for
the Sahara Desert so the desert desert
which keeps happening matcha tea is
powdered TT the La Brea Tar pit in Los
Angeles are the the tar tar pits Timor
lest is East the East there's even the
Milky Way galaxy galaxy comes from the
ancient Greek Gala meaning milk
presumably because it looks like milk
spilled across the sky there's a lot of
these and that's if the translation
stays intact there's a 2p word umboke
which describes a way of cooking meat
over a fire that was borrowed into
French as Buca someone who used that
method of cooking meat because they were
say on a long Voyage was therefore a
Buccaneer or in English a Buccaneer or
the word for a king in Persian Shah was
eventually borrowed over and over again
across multiple languages over centuries
of trading to arrive in English as the
words chess and Czech and sure of course
sometimes we borrow a word that we
already have it's just traveled by a
different route and been changed in two
different ways those are called doublets
grain and corn both come from the same
proto-indo-european root one directly
inherited from English as Germanic roots
and one through romance languages Ward
and guard both come from French at
different times an anime comes from
Japan which borrowed animation from
English often when a word's being
borrowed the grammar doesn't quite work
out the new language keeps the other
bits that are Clinging On called affixes
and Clinics and those get baked into the
long word itself loads of words in
English that start with ow come from
Arabic Albatross comes from Al gatas the
diver algebra from Al Java which
originally meant healing and resetting
broken bones the term for this is
re-bracketing my favorite is Admiral
which is said to come from Amir Alma
commander of the water and Amir al-ba
commander of the sea so Admiral is sort
of commander of the and then we just
lost what they were commander of but
English received those long words from
French which might have gotten from
Latin so every time they moved language
they got well remodeled a bit as
speakers adapted them to sound local
because of course we do if I suddenly
told Spanish mid-sentence for something
like Puerto Rico I the sound pretentious
or foolish or claiming to be a lot
better at Spanish than I actually am I'm
also going to use that as an excuse for
all my appalling pronunciations of
non-english words in this video I'm
sorry to the rest of the world
that's a British sentence so those are
loan words the second way that words get
translated across languages is much
simpler and those words are called calcs
This is where a word is divided into its
component parts Each of which then gets
translated the most well-known example
is skyscraper in the first half of the
20th century many languages were
suddenly in need of a word to describe
buildings that are really really big now
tall sales on a ship were already called
skyscrapers two words and it's possible
that's where the word for the buildings
came from it got hyphenated and then
combined over time like a lot of words
do but even languages who never had the
concept of skyscraper sales just
translated the two parts and that leads
to my favorite bit of this whole thing
loanword is a copy of the German word
for the concept leanvot it has its two
parts separately translated and joined
back together
calc on the other hand is borrowed
directly from French it means to copy or
Trace
which means that long word is a calc and
calc is a long word
if you want to know more about this then
my co-author Gretchen McCulloch has an
entire episode of the podcast enthusiasm
about it the link is in the description